but first I want to introduce a busy mom
of two who recently reached out to me
check out the video she sent us hi Kelly
I have a two-year-old named Ellie and a
two month old named Mason so you can
imagine these last two months have been
absolutely crazy mommy hasn't had any
time except maybe running for an hour to
Target to get some more diapers and
wipes and anything else these kids need
if I had a day off I would love to
actually take off this mom bun that I've
been rocking for about two years and do
my hair go to a restaurant enjoy a hot
meal enjoy it before it's cold because
I'm not sharing it my two year old or
nursing my two month old actually gonna
eat it and enjoy it anyways I hope you
have a wonderful new show
congratulations on it can't wait to
watch it every day take care bye I'm
actually still trying to find a problem
with what she said because I often go to
Target just get my children wear ammama
every day of my life when I say often I
mean every day except when I'm at work
it's fine actually you're fine but
Ashley asked us for some help so I
enlisted someone pretty amazing to help
her please welcome mom actress and the
genius behind the honest company Jessica
Alba yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Jessica's my first guest today but she
came early to help ash when I say early
I mean she's been here all day she I
love her like true story I've been here
all day like we won't come up with a
segment girl don't you threaten me with
a good time okay tell everyone know why
you wanted to help Ashley because I
think this is awesome yeah so I wanted
to help Ashley because I have three kids
myself and I found that after I had kids
and going back to work it's really hard
to find time for me to pamper myself and
when I take the time to pamper myself
and to feel good I feel like I'm a
better person I'm showing up better
every day and I feel like someone who
has spent so much time like she has
dedicated to her family and she just had
a two month old she has a two year old
and it's a lot of other babies and they
need a lot of her I mean not only are
they physically depleting her body but
you know memory but also like just the
lack of sleep and all the things that go
with it so I was like let's give her a
day where she feels loved and pampered
and that's what it's about her
I I'm gonna be honest I was so excited
that you came here today and this is no
lie when I was excited to meet you but
also I have the worst allergies with
makeup no no like it's real because you
have a whole new makeup line yeah I have
all the allergies I get rashes like you
wouldn't believe I would have cystic
acne is what I thought I have to you
know basically from like age 12 until I
stopped working full-time and I was
pregnant and I was like oh wait maybe
it's just the makeup they're putting on
me every day yeah and that's what it was
I'm excited to use to make up time being
real like I cannot wait and I hope I
can't wait for you to try it well we've
got a clip of Jessica surprising Ashley
I'll take a look okay guys I am about to
pull Ashley out of the line or any
surprise makeover this should be fun
almost as fun as me matching wall
[Music]
I'm Jessica will you come with me yeah
we have a surprise you're very trusting
just coming with a stranger into a
mysterious place do you know why you're
here
um kind not once why I'm sitting here
with you I don't know why I'm so we are
going to give you a makeover when was
the last time you can hurt yourself um
before I was pregnant with my son I have
a brand of beauty products skincare and
makeup and so I will be your personal
makeup artist that's amazing do you
trust me yeah
[Applause]
are you ready this is rusty are you
ready are you ready to see Ash's new
look yes yes okay cool there's nothing
wrong with a mom bun okay let's remind
everyone what actually look like when
she got here today all right all right
come on out here Ashley
[Applause]
Oh
oh wait you look so beautiful wait how
do you feel how do you feel amazing I
just saw myself for the first time right
now look here that I'm not her that's
you created Ashley the entire look tell
us about it go ahead so you know she's
32 she's super young and you know I feel
like when you become a mom is when you
really step into yourself and your
sexiness and your sassiness and your
fear small a lot of woman all the things
and I just wanted her to look on the
outside how she feels on the inside and
this is the you know I think you look I
look like a mom but every day my dress
like okay I'll clean up all right you
look so beautiful okay where did you
learn to do makeup there's really good
that's good
you only knew hack didn't stuff like one
okay I was basically my mom in to
cosmetology school when I was little and
so I was her Barbie head and like
basically how I bonded with my mom
growing up was we used to like get ready
to go out wherever it was and it was
always the getting ready that was more
fun than wherever we went
Oh a good time she'd like make
margaritas okay sounds like torture to
me as a kid but I loved that you loved
it you have a two-year-old right you
yeah girl right he's already gotten into
the makeup so she's into it okay look
closer we don't want to take up your
space of looking beautiful
[Applause]
why do you turn around here let's back
up the move so everybody can see your
beautiful self so you see what do you
think she looks beautiful is always
beautiful no matter what okay here's my
question for you because I can only
imagine getting a call and like you wake
up in the morning and they're like so
Jessica Alba is gonna be doing your
makeup I like even me right now I would
like okay like let's do it guys even as
she was doing it I was first I never
thought would happen a million years I
would mean a million guesses never said
that but when I'm sitting back there as
she's doing I'm just in I'm in a dream
this is not realistic I'm still feel
like I'm in a dream right now this isn't
happening like you were being so chill
right now thank you in the halls and I
was like I don't I didn't want to see
you I saw the paper and they weren't
letting you look at yourself and I was
so excited so I rose I didn't get high
now now I feel like a jerk doing really
really well and you know y'all can
recreate this look at home because
everyone's going home with a gift bag
filled with honest beauty products I
will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this